hey guys I'm Jess I'm Dan and you're
watching games but news thanks for doing
that
long time naughty dog employee and
co-director of the Last of Us Bruce
Straley has announced he is leaving the
studio strahle started at Naughty Dog as
a texture artist and slowly worked his
way up to become Co game director on
uncharted 2 with Amy Hennig and
uncharted 4 in the Last of Us with Neil
druckmann when the Last of Us part 2 was
announced it was revealed that Straley
would not be returning to help direct
and was instead taking some time away
from the studio after uncharted 4 it was
in this time that he made the decision
to move on on the Naughty Dog blog he
thanks his co-workers and the fans and
sums it up by saying I too get to
anticipate the next Naughty Dog must
piece next up the new Ghost Recon
wildlands PvP mode ghost war will be
hitting open beta very soon ghosts war
is a 4v4 mode that supports revives and
will hit open beta on September 21st to
25th the PvP mode plays out as the best
of three with 10 minute rounds
unfortunately the mode doesn't support
any more complex objectives or vehicles
at least for now at launch there will be
8 maps and 12 classes available Ghost
Recon wildlands was the best-selling
game in the first half of 2017 if you
haven't given it a try for yourself you
can grab a free trial on ps4 and Xbox
one that will allow you to place for the
first 5 hours of the game finally
Nintendo held the direct this morning
and oh boy did they show off some cool
stuff here's some of the highlights
let's start with the older handheld the
3ds we got some new details on Pokemon
Sun and Moon Ultra including new dusk
and dawn forms you can also get a rock
ruff that will evolve into a like and
rock if you purchase Pokemon Center moon
ultra before January 10 of 2018
next up minecraft is out today on new
3ds and new 2d s this version features
both survival and creative modes and it
allows you to switch between touch and
button controls a packaged version is on
its way but no word on when that will
appear on shelves if you're a Mario
Party fan you'll be happy to you
Nintendo is collecting all the best
party games from the series into one
game called Mario Party the top 100
which will arrive on November 10th
switching to the switch a lot of huge
games are on their way for your little
Nintendo box the publisher revealed that
Skyrim will arrive on switch on November
17th in North America and Europe the
switch version comes with the base game
and it's three expansions and should you
feel so inclined it can also be played
with motion control
but there's this switch investment
doesn't stop there though both doom and
Wolfenstein to the new Colossus will
also come to Nintendo's hybrid console
we don't have a lot of info on either
yet but Nintendo did reveal that doom
will arrive sometime this holiday while
Wolfenstein 2 will be out sometime next
year
the shooter arrives on ps4 Xbox one and
PC on the 27th of October amiibo fans
will be happy to hear that the champions
amiibo for collection of Zelda breath of
the wild are releasing on November 10th
scanning the figures in game unlocks a
helmet
based on that champions respective
divine based Nintendo also dropped a ton
of info on the switches upcoming
open-world RPG Xenoblade Chronicles turf
which will arrive on December 1st there
will be a standard release and a limited
100 dollar special edition as well as a
Xenoblade pro controller that's on the
way Nintendo also showed off a lengthy
new look at Mario Odyssey with way more
information about the game including the
reveal of a photo mode which is well
worth checking out for yourself for more
on these stories and everything that we
couldn't fit into this news episode make
sure you check back to our stories on
GameSpot to get all caught up that's
everything we have for you today enjoy
the rest of your day and we'll be back
tomorrow morning giving you all the news
you'll ever need we'll see you then
you